good morning John last Sunday tens of
thousands of people took to the streets
in Hong Kong to protest police reactions
to these protests were surprisingly
intense resulting in get this far more
people joining the protest this somewhat
surprising result is only one of the
things that can be explained through a
better understanding of what Hong Kong
is what those people are protesting
about and what is motivating China a
brief history 1847 Hong Kong a sparsely
populated island off the southern coast
of China is ceded to the United Kingdom
after the opium war 1898 China and Hong
Kong agree to a 99-year lease of Hong
Kong to the British Empire to be a
British colony matter not years that's
that's plenty of time to figure out in
the 90s with the switch impending the
appointed not elected governor of Hong
Kong started to talk about how it would
be really great if Hong Kong we're a
democracy this is kind of hilarious
after 150 years of colonial rule defines
this not just hilarious but also really
annoying because China would like to
have Hong Kong's extraordinarily
economically important cake and also eat
its 1997 after 150 years of British rule
Hong Kong becomes part of China kinda
after hundred and fifty years Hong Kong
has its own dialect and judiciary in
taxes and postal service and money and
culture people from Hong Kong are
ethnically Chinese and they feel
connected to the Chinese people there
don't consider themselves Chinese they
get an idea of how weird this is if you
want to go from China to China but you
happen to be crossing the Hong Kong
border you have to get your passport
stamped and go through immigration to
get a better idea of how weird this is
during the 2008 Beijing Olympics both
China and Hong Kong had separate teams
same country at the root of it this is
all because what Hong Kong is now is
really great for China not only would it
be extremely difficult to have Hong Kong
run by the same system as China which
would be completely different from the
entire culture of Hong Kong it would
also be bad for China China wants Hong
Kong to be the thing that it is it's a
capitalist powerhouse that was created
as a bridge between China and the
capitalist world Hong Kong houses the
third largest Stock Exchange in the
world the Hong Kong dollar is the eighth
most traded currency in the world raw
that to keep working Hong Kong kinda has
to be a thing that China finds really
uncomfortable free they call it one
country two systems'
alright this might be a little bit of a
difficult thing to understand in America
when we make fun of a politician on TV
that's not just okay it's also like if
that politician can handle it it's kind
of a good thing for them it makes them
seem more powerful in China where
everything is very tightly controlled
that kind of criticism would make a
politician seem extremely weak you have
to imagine China is being run by a
culture that does not accept any kind of
derision or appearance of weakness the
crazy with the control China's national
day was this week and they let loose
10,000 doves in Tiananmen Square
they cavity searched every dove to make
sure there were no explosives inside of
them that is what you think it is
China's government attitude is a mixture
of immense pride in what they have done
and vulnerability just fear of it
falling apart and that might be somewhat
warranted because there are lots of
areas of China that don't want to be
areas of China and with a weakening
economy and the number of protests in
China growing politicians are worried
about losing stability and they really
like stability now add to all of this
that the current president of China Xi
Jingping just did a massive crackdown on
corruption made him a lot of enemies of
the Chinese officials who were
benefitting from corruption you have a
situation where the leadership in
Beijing really wants to appear strong
and in control and not at all weak and
is thus not in any way interested to
conceding to the protests in Hong Kong
or even allowing them to continue
protest itself does probably hurt
Beijing though maybe not as much as they
imagined because people in Hong Kong and
people in China don't actually get along
that well anymore for reasons that
surprisingly involve shopping excursions
now I got in the long way into this and
I haven't even talked about the reason
why people started protesting last
Sunday and that's kind of because with
all this background it starts to feel
inevitable like it's just a thing that
was gonna happen here's the specific
since the handoff of Hong Kong to China
it has been run not by a governor or a
mayor but a chief executive if it wasn't
capitalist enough for a chief executive
is elected by a kind of like weird
Electoral College composed mostly of
like business tycoons that represent
different constituencies mostly
corporate constituencies now Hong Kong's
Constitution which isn't really a
constitution eventually calls for the
election of the chief executive by the
people not by a group of 1200 people who
have the exact same interests as Beijing
but Beijing interprets that law a little
bit differently saying that yes the
citizens of Hong Kong can elect their
chief executive but they have to choose
from a pool of candidate
that Beijing pre-selects for them and
that of course is not a democracy maybe
even more importantly since the 1989
massacre at Tiananmen Square the people
of Hong Kong have had a proud and strong
history of demonstration and protest and
the intense response from the Hong Kong
police was maybe even more scary to the
people of Hong Kong than was the
prospect of not being able to elect
their own leaders if the people of Hong
Kong have never been able to elect their
own leaders but they have been able to
freely protest some people hope that as
Hong Kong was a testing ground for
China's unique form of capitalism it
might also become a testing ground for
actual Chinese democracy the cultural
gap between the structure and control of
China and the freedom of Hong Kong may
be too big to bridge so while the
protests are bad for the image of
Chinese leaders quashing them would be
bad for the continued economic
prosperity of Hong Kong the protesters
know that they shouldn't mess too much
with Beijing that's why they're
directing most of their ire at the chief
executive China state media meanwhile
does report on the protests in Hong Kong
just like they reported on the protest
of the Arab Spring but as they did with
the Arab Spring they focus on the chaos
and inconvenience that these protests
bring and really what China needs is to
stick together and be stable yayyyy
stability and with the protesters in
Hong Kong protesting in very calm and
stable ways there seems to be a certain
amount of agreement the stability is
good there aren't very many voices
calling for Hong Kong to secede from
China though China may be afraid that
with continued cultural changes that may
eventually be the case mostly Hong Kong
just wants to be Hong Kong an
exceptional unique place where lots of
amazing things happen ideally a Hong
Kong with a little bit more control over
its own destiny for really the first
time in its entire existence but in the
country where they check the butts of
pigeons for explosives having an entire
7 million person part of the country not
controlled by the central government is
maybe not just scary it might be just a
completely foreign concept so just as
China found ways to allow actual
capitalism to occur within its borders
maybe there's a way for actual democracy
to occur within its borders that would
be pretty amazing and that would be a
pretty fantastic outcome to this very
very weird story I guess we'll see John
I'll see you on Tuesday
you